foreign
[Music]
binsberg and a finance professor at the
Wharton School of the University of
Pennsylvania and I'm Jonathan Burke a
financial professor at The Graduate
School of Business at Stanford
University and this is the all else
equal podcast
welcome back everybody today we're going
to talk about shareholder versus
stakeholder capitalism this is a topic
that has received a lot of attention
recently so let's first explain exactly
what it is that we're talking about
let's start with what exactly is
shareholder capitalism so sharehold of
capitalism is the idea that the purpose
of a firm is to maximize the value of
the firm to the shareholders meaning
that the profits that the firm generates
are accruing to the shareholders and
that's what you're trying to maximize
now one statement that you recently hear
a lot about shareholder capitalism is
Cheryl capitalism makes firms focus on
short-term profits and thus will steer
firms away from long-term value creation
what do you think about that Jonathan
you know I always laugh at that because
the same people who claim that shelter
capitalism is short term Lord The
Venture Capital industry in Silicon
Valley what could be more long-term than
a shareholder and Equity investment in a
startup most of these startups are not
expecting dividends for 20 30 years if
at all I think what people are confusing
in this case Jonathan has the question
of does the stock price reflect the
present value of all the future profits
of the firm versus what is the holding
period that a particular investor holds
a stock for so even if you decide to
only hold a stock for say six months
that doesn't mean that at each point in
time the price of the stock reflects all
of the profits going forward so as long
as you try to maximize that stock price
you are actually doing long-term value
maximization perfectly consistent with
the long-term value creation yes because
even if you're holding the stock for the
short term
at the end of that term you have to sell
it to somebody and that person has to
Value it so like go back to venture
capital when the Venture capitalists
invest and say a successful startup
their objective is to get out long
before the firm makes profits so they
are short-term investors yet they very
much care about the long term because
they know when they get out they have to
sell to other investors who care about
the long term yes so one thing that we
have established is that if we're going
to have a discussion about a different
model than shareholder capitalism the
argument that we need a different model
because shareholder capitalism doesn't
focus enough on the long term doesn't
seem like a particularly convincing
argument but that doesn't prevent people
from saying that it's time for a new
model and so recently we've been hearing
a lot about stakeholder capitalism who
are these stakeholders of the firm that
people are talking about so generally we
think about the employees of the firm or
the customers of the firm the suppliers
of the firm neighbors that live around
the firm perhaps even all of society and
what you often hear in this context is
that they all must be represented
equally and to tell the truth Jonathan I
never quite understand what exactly that
means yes that neither do I Jules I
don't know you know you could think
about various different stakeholders
further and further away from the firm
what about future Generations that are
affected by the firm Are they also
representative equilini I think a pretty
vague term but with that said I think an
important question to ask is when do
shareholder capitalism and stakeholder
capitalism not come to the same
decisions
no for sure and so I think we need to be
open to the possibility that firm
activities have externalities meaning
the things that the firm does affects
other people sometimes in ways that
isn't quite priced by the market and
because there's no price on it the
decision makers inside the firm may be
ignoring these externalities when
they're making their choices
if it's good for shareholders and good
for stakeholders then obviously the
shareholder model a mistakeholder model
give the same answer so it's not an
interesting question similarly if it's
bad for shareholders and bad for
stakeholders they also give the same
answer so the only interesting case is
when they disagree with each other what
if I have a firm that is polluting that
it's good for shareholders but bad for
stakeholders and the question is how
should the decision be made under what
the firm should do yeah so let's do a
simple example suppose that there is a
firm that wants to do fishing in a lit
and because there's a lot of fish in the
lake
there are lots of birds that hang around
this Lake let's think about the people
that live on the lake as owning a firm
together they're the shareholders of the
lake and they start fishing and
obviously they're maximizing their
profits which reduces the number of
birds in the area now clearly this has a
negative externality there for for the
people that don't own the lake and don't
immediately live on the lake and the
question is what should be done in this
particular case because there's a firm
activity there are shareholders they're
maximizing their profits by fishing and
there's a negative externality from the
activity which is the birds that are no
longer there after we fish too much so
now how are we going to solve this issue
I think the answer is the government
taxes people fishing on the lake to make
up for the externality of the Lost Birds
I agree in principle the government
could solve this couple of of its notes
though first of all
how do we set that tax rate
that is already a very complicated
question right because suppose that we
would survey the people that live in
that neighborhood and ask them how
important are these birds to you now
clearly if they know that the government
will set the tax rate based on the
answer that they give they have a huge
moral hazard problem in the sense that
they're going to over report what
exactly the value of these birds is to
them and so how is the government
exactly going to decide how to set that
tax rate but more importantly just
abstracting from that issue I think that
a lot of people that adhere or are
arguing for the stakeholder model they
sort of have come to the conclusion that
the government isn't effective in
addressing these issues in other words
the Democratic process is either too
slow or too ineffective to solve these
large problems of externalities like
pollution so let's take the government
solving this problem off the table for a
second what would we do in that case
well I know would you want me to say you
want me to say that we should put
stakeholders on the board of the company
that decides who's fishing a lake and
they can represent their interests and
reduce the amount of fishing to bring
back the birds
sure that would be one option although
of course it's not so easy there either
right because how many board seats
exactly are we going to give to these
people it's said that all the
stakeholders need to be equally
represented but what does that mean I I
mean I'm not sure but okay if we assume
everybody is no government and we put
the stakeholders on the board of the
lake then yes there'll be less Fishing
and More Birds but when I where I have a
problem with is why then stop with birds
once you put those stakeholders on the
board what did they say okay actually we
also want a beach on the lake in other
words how do we know the stakeholders
will only represent the externalities
they won't also represent their own
selfish interests
we need to know exactly how important
everybody's interests are and how we're
going to trade them off against each
other and I think that's the biggest
weakness of the stakeholder model first
of all it isn't very well defined who
exactly can be counted as a stakeholder
even if we had a very well-defined group
of people how are we going to treat the
interests of all these people off
against each other it seems like a
particularly daunting task to me I would
say the biggest issue is that
stakeholders who have no interest in the
profits of the firm don't take into
account how the actions reduce the
profits assume we have a firm and the
employees are represented on the board
and the employees give themselves a pay
increase so that the no more dividends
to pay to equity holders just enough so
the firm survives but doesn't grow and
so then
potential future customers of the firm
are hurt and all the potential future
employees that they would have been
hired had the firm grown or hurt
obviously current Equity holders are
hurt because presumably they expected a
dividend otherwise they wouldn't have
invested anyway all to the benefit of
current employees the problem with
putting other people on the board is
they are making decisions where they
don't bear the costs and that's a
terrible idea yeah so the incentives are
not aligned absolutely
and of course I understand that Sheldon
will make decisions to maximize their
own benefit at the cost of societal
benefits but to me the answer is not to
try to solve it within the firm the way
to solve that is to have a responsible
government
that taxes the externalities I think
most people would agree with that too
but we're struggling with right now is
what is the most effective system
pragmatically to make all of this happen
and so given the fact that governments
for such a long time haven't been as
successful as some people would like
they are now looking for other models
and the stakeholder model is just one of
those options but I don't have higher
hopes for the stakeholder model of
solving these problems relative to the
governments that are trying to solve
them okay I think that was a very good
time to introduce our guests Jules Our
Guest this Alex Edmonds who is a finance
professor at the London Business School
he has written a recent book on the
topic of shareholder versus stakeholder
capitalism called grow to pie he's an
expert in the area that we've just been
discussing and we're very happy to have
him on the podcast welcome Alex thanks
so much chills and Jonathan for having
me on it's it's great to be here we're
so excited to have you on so maybe I
think to kick the discussion off it
would be helpful if you could maybe
elaborate a bit on what in your opinion
is the key difference between what many
people know as shareholder capitalism or
the shareholder model and stakeholder
capitalism I actually think there's far
fewer differences than you might think
and you might think well doesn't that
sound crazy isn't a shareholder or a
company somebody only focused on
short-term profit and wanted to exploit
everybody else but that's not the case
because you opened up Jonathan's
textbook shareholder value is a
long-term concept that it's the present
value of all future cash flows from now
until the end of time and that's not
just in theory it's there in practice if
you look at the valuations of Teslas of
the world that is based on more than
just short-term earnings so actually if
a company is focused on shareholder
value it will take stakeholders
seriously you have to treat your
employees well otherwise they'll leave
you can't pollute the environment
otherwise customers will stop buying and
you have to provide great customer
service but I still think there are
differences and there are a couple and I
think the most important one is
externalities so there are certain
impacts that a company will have on
society which even in the long term will
not feed through to shareholder value so
one might be carbon emissions if there
is not a fair carbon tax then this is
something that a shareholder Focus
company will not consider but still that
doesn't suggest going towards
stakeholder capitalism because there is
another party you can deal with
externalities which is the government
through taxation
and it's not just the government but
there's also ethical codes Milton
Friedman argued that companies should
not only obey the law but also follow
ethical customers so I think the key
difference is when there's an
externality and the externality is not
dealt with by the government and that
could be for two reasons one of them is
the government failed to do something
about it when it could like a carbon tax
and the other is there's some things
which are just very difficult to
regulate so how do you regulate a
company having a great corporate culture
meaningful work anti-discrimination and
so on obviously there's business reasons
for wanting to implement that but there
could be societal reasons for that and
they stay called a focused company will
try to minimize those externalities
above and beyond the business case for
doing so but Alex aren't we just asking
businesses to do something that you know
human beings aren't very good at but
just think about others don't people
just think about themselves yeah so this
is why if you want to move to a state
called uh capitalism model there had to
be some constraints that has to be
accountability otherwise anything goes
how do we know which stakeholders to
address you and I might have different
views right if you're an energy company
you shut down a polluting plant that's
good for the environment it's bad for
workers and it could be bad for the
company and it could be bad for the
shareholders which might include Pension
funds so I think if you are going to
have an objective other than long-term
shelter value you need to have a clear
shareholder mandate and there could be
ways of doing this so one thing I've
developed with a colleague Tom Gosling
is the idea of a say on purpose which
would be an advisory vote that
shareholders can have on non-financial
objectives you might know of say on
climate this has become quite popular
but purpose is more than just climate
there's many other stakeholders beyond
the environments and you don't need to
formalize it like that but there needs
to be a way of getting shareholder
buy-in because otherwise when a company
is pursuing these other goals it is
spending shareholders money you can't
just have a CEO pursuing his or her pet
cause without this mandate from the
ultimate owners of the business we used
to teach this case at Stanford on Google
if you look at Google's RPO and the
stated documents in Google's IPO the
number one rule was do no evil and they
were very explicit we don't care about
profits we care about doing no evil so
there was a case where the stakeholder
model was explicit and as we know Google
is nothing like that
well if indeed company say something and
then they do something else that is bad
for shareholders but I would say that is
no worse than in any other business
decision so the company says we are
going to be Innovative and they're not
doing that or the company says we're
going to expand geographically and they
end up sort of taking the quiet life
that is also bad for shareholders so
what is strange is we have this issue of
green washing which is when companies
say something or they don't deliver and
absolutely that needs to be taken
seriously however I would say it should
be taken as seriously as any other
business decision where companies say
something and they don't deliver on that
Alex just to push you a little on this I
would say we have to recognize the
constraints in human behavior they could
say do no evil but when they start doing
business they will follow their own
what's good for them and that inevitably
will mean they will do quote unquote
evil I mean when it comes down to
putting me first and somebody else first
people put themselves first well there's
a couple of things that you can do to
address that so what really matters is
incentives as you say so one thing that
some companies are doing are trying to
lengthen the Horizon of CEO incentives
including linking it being on the CEO's
tenure so they're required to hold
shares even after their departure so
some of the externalities might not
manifest within the CEO's tenure but
might manifest afterwards but you still
might think well even if you're holding
your shares after the CEOs left the
externalities might still not manifest
and therefore this is for other things
such as Government intervention to come
in so one of the issues with stakeholder
capitalism exactly as you say is that
companies may say things and not deliver
on this and this is why I do think the
government needs to step in and take
some action because in the absence of
that just companies saying oh believe me
I'm gonna care about wider Society you
might not deliver on this so we saw this
with the Business Roundtable statement
181 CEOs claim that they're going to
serve word of society but when the
rubber hit the road they didn't actually
deliver on this so we know this in
economics as cheap talk if there's not a
credible way to commit towards a
particular source of action then you may
will just deviate and then do what
maximizes your own profit so Alex in the
context of that I had a following
question for you I've heard you speak
about this before and I would love for
you to elaborate a little bit on this we
have particular competitive advantages
for particular institutions and we also
have particular purposes for particular
institutions right and one thing that I
think is behind the discussion you and
Jonathan were just having is the
question of well do corporations
actually have a competitive advantage in
fixing all of the issues that are
generally brought up when we do speak
about stakeholder capitalism so I have
two questions for you one is do you
think that corporations have a
competitive advantage or can develop
such a competitive advantage or how can
shareholders make them develop such a
competitive Advantage if at all the
second question that I'm very interested
in is why now so much compared to say 10
10 years ago or 20 years ago because it
seems to really have taken a flight I
think most of it Remains the cheap talk
but everybody is pledging allegiance to
these higher causes and I'm just curious
why we're seeing this now so much more
than before
and two really good questions so let me
start with the first one so do companies
have a competitive Advantage absolutely
so just as they have a competitive
advantage in generating profits they
might be able to leverage that
competitive advantage to address a
social issue so let me give an example
Vodafone is the UK telecoms giant they
had a technology which allowed people to
send text messages to each other they
leverage that and developed m-pesa which
is a mobile money service where you can
send money from person to person just as
you could easily send a text message and
so that means the Vodafone out of all
the societal issues that it could have
been solving climate change biodiversity
and so on it shows to solve Financial
inclusion and I think that is really
important because one interpretation of
stakeholder capitalism is let's try to
solve all of the world's problems let's
try to take every single of the 17
sustainable development goals but I
don't think companies should do that
because of the constraints that are
Jonathan mentioned earlier if you're
going to be in a field in which you
don't have expertise you're going to be
spending a lot of money and actually if
you are going to make a verbal
commitment to that you probably are not
going to deliver on it why because it's
going to cost you so much whereas if you
are developing a commitment like
Vodafone to build a digital society that
enhances socioeconomic progress that is
something with some credibility because
you are using expertise you can create a
lot of shareholder value without
actually much cost and what is really
interesting is that it might profit them
later why because if you're creating
value for society ultimately people will
pay you for that and it was able to
monetize m-pesa so for me one of the
more compelling reasons for stakeholder
capitalism is if this inspires you to
take some actions that you might not
have done otherwise and those actions
May well end up leading to a profit if
it's based on your competitive Advantage
like I don't know why you and Jonathan
set up this podcast to begin in with I'm
sure it wasn't a profit calculation and
maybe somebody ends up listening to this
podcast and thinks oh these are two
really cool Finance professors let me
give them some data so they can write
another paper or let me invite them to
speak at a conference but you never sort
of made that calculation instead if
you're creating and disseminating
knowledge using comparative advantage
later on you might benefit
so the second question you asked is why
now and I think there's two reasons and
both reasons I think there's a
legitimate part and an illegitimate part
so the first reason is the business case
so people are realizing that many of
these State called their issues do end
up improving profits in the long term I
had a paper in the jfe in 2011 showing
that employee satisfaction ultimately
boosts long-term Shield returns however
you do have many studies Often by
consultancies claiming that every single
ESG issue pays off in long-term
performance and because of confirmation
bias people will lap that up
uncritically because it's what they
would like to believe so I think many
practitioners believe the business case
is much stronger than it actually is
that ESG investing will always improve
returns so that's one reason
I think the second reason is the
recognition that companies do have an
impact on wider Society for example in
the pandemic you had alcohol companies
pivoting to make sanitizer and saving a
huge amount of lives and many of those
shareholders even though there was a
cost to that may have been willing to
pay that cost to save life but again
here there needs to be some Nuance is
that you shouldn't then end up trying to
solve all of the world's problems and I
think people think now companies should
try to address all of those stakeholder
issues so we do see this Mission creep
where yes we realize that we can have a
positive impact on society but in many
cases this is through doing our Core
Business in a great way so Alex well
John Cochran was on the show he viewed
stakeover capitalism as a veiled attempt
to increase government influence in the
private sector what's your view of that
my view is quite nuanced as it has been
for a number of these questions so I
actually don't think it's bad for
stakeholder capitalists to try to
influence the government why because the
government does have a comparative
advantage in addressing some issues with
tools like Taxation and regulation that
nobody else has so as an investor I
think it's much better for you to try to
persuade the government to implement a
carbon tax than for you to do things
like divest from fossil fuel companies
which your paper has shown is not
effective to begin with however I don't
think stakeholder capitalism should be a
way of supplanting the government by
trying to sort of override issues that
the government can decide for itself so
one topic I've done a lot of research on
is is CEO pay and people say well we
don't like CEOs being paid a lot because
this leads to inequality however the
government has a tool to address
inequality which is income tax so you do
have some investors as a mother
stakeholders saying we're going to vote
against a high pay package for the CEO
irrespective of whether she's deserved
it through creating long-term value
because we just don't like inequality
but I think unless we believe that the
tax rate that the governor set has been
lobbied or is not reflecting the
electorate's preferences I think that's
an issue which should be left to the
government more recently in the UK we
have this quite prominent case where
sainsbury is one of the supermarkets
there was a proposal for them to pay the
living wage which is significantly
higher than the minimum wage and
actually that got opposition from some
responsible investors because they said
well this is really going to put the
costs under out of control and
jeopardize the sustainability of the
business yes we do want to treat work as
well but there is a minimum wage that
the government has already set and
there's no clear reason why the
government has said this wrongly so we
should not support the government by
trying to change what is something which
has been Justified finally set by the
government
all right Alex thank you so much I mean
this is excellent now it's really great
Alex thank you so much thanks really
enjoyed the conversation
thanks for listening to the all else
equal podcast please leave us a review
at Apple podcasts we love to hear from
our listeners and be sure to catch our
Next Episode by subscribing or following
our show wherever you listen to your
podcasts for more information and
episodes visit all else
equalpodcast.com or follow us on
LinkedIn
the ol SQL podcast is a production of
Stanford University's Graduate School of
Business and is produced by alumni FM
[Music]